JOSH LIVNI: Hi, everybody.
My name is Josh Livni,
welcome to Google
Maps Developers Live.
So this week I want to talk to
you about a new layer in the
Maps API that lets you render
private or public content
that's stored in Google
Maps Engine in a
pretty cool new way.
So to get a little bit of
context, first I want to show
you here on my screen a
demonstration of our Maps
Engine layer, which has been
out for awhile, and renders
data sets that are stored
in Google Maps Engine.
So what I have here is some
watersheds, some reasonably
complex polygons.
Not too many of them, but it
could potentially be millions
of features here.
Same general technique.
And the workflow that's going
on behind the scenes is this
data is being rendered on our
servers as image tiles.
There's a lot of products that
sort of use the same approach,
so nothing particularly
new here.
And what we can do generally
with this approach is we get a
little slightly different
cursor as we mouse over.
We can have click events.
Usually it opens
an info window.
Here I'm just zooming into
that particular feature.
So nothing new here.
That's our Maps Engine layer.
It's cool, lets you display
tons of complex data sets.
Very fast.
You'll notice as we
zoom in and out it
renders very quickly.
So now let's take a look at our
new dynamic Maps Engine
layer, and some of
the differences.
So here we have the exact same
data set, exact same sort of
general code, except we're
calling the dynamic Maps
Engine layer instead of the Maps
Engine layer in our code.
And I've added some
extra handling.
And some of handling that we
can do is take advantage of
new mouse events.
So you'll notice as I hover
over, I'm dynamically
redrawing the polygons that
I'm getting mouse over and
mouse out events on.
And when I click on a polygon
here, what it's doing is it's
loading up another Maps engine
layer, a dynamic Maps Engine
layer, excuse me, of the sub
watersheds for a given watershed.
And similarly here as I mouse
over, I get different events
getting fired from the dynamic
Maps Engine layer, and I can
pay attention to those
and redraw.
I can also, if you take a look
at the info box on the left,
get some information from the
features, and put some
information in there.
And the way that I'm doing that
on the back end is I'm
using the Maps Engine API
to download some feature
information, and then
do a look up.
As I mouse over here I get the
feature ID, I do a look up
into the Maps Engine API
response, and paint that
information, such as the area
of the sub watershed in this
little box here.
So a lot of cool things you
can do with this kind of
almost instantaneous redraw.
What's going on behind the
scenes here is similarly,
we're rendering tiles, but this
time it's vector tiles.
And these vector tiles are kind
of optimized for the zoom
level that you're at, simplified
and so forth.
So you get a really snappy
responses as you zoom in,
seeing all of the data in a
nice, kind of small vector
format, and you get this
extra interactivity.
So there's a lot of things
you can do here.
So just a quick look at our
documentation on some ways to
get started.
If you're interested in
rendering public content, you
can do that as well.
People who have stored public
data sets in Maps Engine, or
of course if you have your own
private data, you can use
OAuth, and just make sure that
the people that you want to
have access to it can access
your data using the dynamic
Maps Engine layer.
The documentation here is under
Libraries, under our
JavaScript documentation.
So go to Libraries,
Visualization Library, and
then Maps Engine Layer.
And we have some simple
examples to
kind of get you started.
You'll notice here the Maps
Engine layer, we have just a
basic click on a polygon.
We get kind of our
info window.
Scroll down the dynamic
Maps Engine layer.
We can redraw on the fly with
different kinds of effects
just on hover.
So, pretty cool.
We look forward to seeing
what kind of stuff
you build with this.
Let us know on feedback
below this video,
or on Google+ Twitter.
We love to see the kinds of
things you guys are doing, and
hope you enjoy the new dynamic
Maps Engine layer.
Until next time, I'm Josh Livni,
have a great week.